[MUSIC]
>> Somewhere between when we're a baby and
when we're a fully functioning
member of society, we come to reach
a decision about what we're capable of.
When I go around the world asking
the question, who's a great leader?
People bring up names from Gandhi,
great political leaders in history,
JFK and the like.
The ones who come to mind when you think
about people you admire is that they
are known for continuing their
development throughout their lives.
Clearly, there’s a developmental process.
And yet at some point, we come to the
conclusion that there are some things we
can do and some things we can’t do.
These exceptional leaders
are not born exceptional.
They didn’t know a thing.
They became something over their lives and
the question is can you become
something over your life?
Write down something you want to do to
develop yourself personally in terms of
development and growth mindset.
Write down something that you would
like to do that would make you better at
affecting others in your organization
that way, creating a context for
others to flourish.
And write down a change that you can make
in yourself that you think would impact
the broader environment.
Make them your personal commitment to
develop yourself at all three of these
levels.
>> Transform your Approach to
Leadership Excellence and Development.
Learn more about SEP,
the Stanford Executive Program.
[MUSIC]